فيلم فروزن وبلغته الام الانجليزيه يدخل
الى مدرسه في كوريا الشماليه كي يتمكن
الطلاب من تعلم اللغه الانجليزيه المحظوره
مع متحدثيها الاصليين في تلك البلاد وفق
ما كشفته صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه
احد افلام ديزني حقق نجاحا عالميا عام
2013 اخترته المدرسه الكوريه كي تسهل على
الطلاب استخدام اللغه الانجليزيه ونطقها
جيدا مما يشير الى التاثير الثقافي
الامريكيه على المجتمع في البلاد زعيم
كوريا الشماليه
كان شجع على اجراء تغييرات بالمناهج
الدراسيه خلاف عن طبعا للقرارات السابقه
التي حضرت فيها استخدام طبعا سلطات البلاد
المواطنين من مشاهده افلام او الاستمتاع
او الاستماع الى موسيقى غير محليه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات